I wouldn't dare try.
I don't even want the possibility of
becoming addicted to something that is
going to make me physical
dependent upon it.
My name is Kayla and
I'm a recovery advocate.
Hi, my name is Chris and I'm a cannabis
advocate. Hi, my name is Devin and a,
I'm fascinated with mental health.
My name is [inaudible],
but the green goes JC and I am a pro.
These things that are grow
out of the ground and make us
shift perspective. My
name is [inaudible]. Um,
I am honestly middle ground.
My name is Kiki Dexter
and I'm here pro marijuana
drugs.
So my sister went to rehab
for a extensive drug's usage.
It affected her life very
heavily and was in rehab cost.
My parents a lot of time, energy, money,
and just emotional draining
for the whole family.
My Dad is a very adamantly trying,
recovering heroin addict.
I think he froze,
got addicted when he was like 2021 it was
the influx of drugs into the cities in
the 80s it still affects his life.
I had a physical dependence on
prescription anti anxiety medication,
Klonopin specifically
for like seven years.
I went to treatment like three years ago.
Um, and eventually found my way back.
I would consider myself sober. I've been
sober for like two and a half years.
Alcohol played a big role in my life.
Marijuana played a big role in my life.
I did notice,
uh,
going into my twenties that the pattern
that I do have a propensity to want to
get fucked up now.
Like I don't smoke,
I don't drink or at least
that's my intention.
But there comes a time when it's like,
cool.
I think I could go for a nice
LSD trip. Woods, that'd be nice.
People often become emotionally
dependent on recreational drugs.
Yeah, I think they do. Um, for
example, I had a great childhood,
but I was sexually abused.
Nobody knew what was going on.
How do you,
by the time I was 14,
I was using whatever I
could get my hands on to,
to deal with the emotional turmoil
that I was dealing with inside. And,
um, when we're so young we have traumatic
events or we have these situations and
these circumstances that stick with us
and we don't know how to process them.
So we reach out to whatever's
closest to is food addiction,
drug addiction.
Um,
I think it's,
it's good to establish a distinction
between recreational use and habitual use
cause that's something I
heard you guys talking about.
And I don't feel that people really
become emotionally dependent when they're
recreationally using it.
When they're habitually using it,
when they're using it to
solve problems, then it, it,
it does become an issue because you're
not dealing with balance at that point.
I mean you're,
you're tipping one way and the scale,
you're clearly going to affect
other areas and get sick.
Okay.
I believe drugs are safe,
moderate
moderation.
I don't know what I think
actually I agree. I
think so. What's up guys?
This was the hard one for me. I just had
that hone in on that word moderation.
Like if I'm smoking once or twice a week,
that's fine.
But if I'm smoking every day of my life,
every second I get up and I
can't function then of, you know,
of course that's when there's a red line.
I wouldn't say like using
things like heroin or cocaine,
like he's not a moderation.
I think that's just harmful.
But if we're talking about the subject
of marijuana and that use, then yeah,
yeah.
Well, here's why I disagree. I
think there are levels to this.
I don't think all drugs are safe,
even in moderation.
Like you take a wrong Molly or whatever
the Percocet pill is like, you know,
like people have died from that and that
was technically in moderation. One pill,
one day, life gone. You know,
like, same thing with heroin.
Like that's something that could
drastically change your life in a day.
The moderation part of it is tough
because with pharmaceuticals mainly to me,
you mix two those things, you're
gone. And that's terrifying.
Yeah.
And there are so many circumstances
where it only takes one time to become
physically dependent.
Even in, in my case, um,
I take prescription
medication for sleeping.
I hate that I'm on it and I hate
that I have to use it to function.
If you don't have to absolutely do it.
Why do it?
So let me ask you this though.
What's the distinction for you
between that and like Iowasca Pod Dmt?
Uh, the different, it's not necessary.
I think there's a distinction that I I'm
going to invite you to look at is like
there is a difference between cocaine.
Oh it was fine.
Hundred percent but what I'm
saying is neither are necessary.
My question to you is,
are you saying to all the young people
like you will not be able to open your
mind fully unless you go and do this?
No. What I'm saying is
that I hold everybody, hi.
And I hold everybody with the
ability to think for themselves,
but also going out and having
an intentional, purposeful,
responsible encounter with mushrooms
or LSD supported me in getting over my
addiction to marijuana and alcohol.
But the point being is the safety issue
and what you might have gone in that
moment when you took the drawings and
it opened her mind and you were able to
realize a lot of stuff I think people
should do on their own without them
drugs,
reduce people's potential.
Okay.
I think even with psychedelic drugs,
you know, to the point earlier,
even if they are opening your mind up,
that's really not your potential,
that's not your potential.
Your potential is the organic potential
and a lot of your organic self is
wonderful and it is marvelous and if you
take a little time to work and develop
that muscle,
like a talent,
then you will be able to reach your
fullest potential. When I got sober,
I went back to school, which I never
thought I would do. I work two jobs,
they started a small business,
like I think of all of the people who
are usually hypersensitive and end up
getting into drugs because I can't deal
with our emotions and all those people
could be potentially adding to society
and they're not because they're in their
own world.
So I, I really don't feel that
they harm people's potential.
I think that helped people gain their
potential in a lot of different ways.
And I mean with cannabis alone,
I mean,
we have an endocannabinoid
system with our body. I mean,
it's one of our main receptors.
It within our brain that it's
like a lock and key for cannabis.
It's w are made at the same materials.
Our brains synthesizes
those materials within it.
So I really do feel that our potential
isn't high hindered by drugs. I mean,
some, it totally, I can see some a
hundred percent but overall natural ones,
not at all.
Some of the most powerful people in the
world right now in silicon valley and
creating some of the most powerful
startups are all microdosing. Oh, totally.
Two years ago I did, I had
my first mushroom experience.
So I went into the woods.
I went in nature,
I set the intention,
I'm going to have this experience
and I've never had before.
It was a remarkable experience and I felt
a deeper truth within my connection to
the earth.
Something I hadn't had in a long time.
And it was kinda this
reconnection with my spirituality.
I can relate to you because I also
come from a very spiritual background.
I think wherever that framework
is for you, like if it's a drug,
then that's for you. I think that's a
dangerous path. I also think that for me,
that that thing is God.
You know,
like me having faith in God and
a relationship with God. That is,
that is the opening to my spirituality.
Like I don't need to
take drugs to get there.
Have you done psychedelics? No. So it,
it's, it's like someone that hasn't done,
had sex talking about,
no, it's not, that's not what it's
like at all. Like because how you,
the thing is is I don't need to
know. That's my point. My point is,
my point is you don't need
to know to have you do it.
Do you have a relationship with Christ
and you know, have you spoken in tongues?
None of the meaning. That's
a cross. That's not a
relationship. They're very dope.
Right. That is not a relationship.
The two are very different.
That's my point. So you don't have to ask
me what I did not do. What I said was,
and I'll repeat it, my experience and
my relationship with Christ, for me,
that supersedes my desire to even go
into that path because I find myself very
happy, very successful, buried.
I'm thriving within my being
and I don't need the stuff
to to,
there is a lot of false information
about recreational drugs.
Sorry,
everyone agree?
No one knows nothing.
It's like based on the culture,
the perception,
and I'm strictly talking about marijuana,
but you know,
at one point in history it was
also used for medicine. It was,
it was used for religion.
It was used for, you know,
for hip was used for a
variety of things like this.
And there's people that don't know
that it's a part of our history.
So when I think about how ill informed
people are, that's one of the main things.
But the truth,
there's like, do I really want all of the
information? I'll be honest. No I don't.
I don't, I don't really need it. You
don't. I agree with the statement.
That's why I walked over because
I will agree that like Vr,
there's a lot that I don't know
about recreational drugs. Um,
and I think that there's a lot
that most people don't know. Yeah.
I mean I walked over for that same thing.
I try and keep an open mind at all times
and realize that a wise man knows that
he knows nothing,
especially with cannabis.
And now I'm aware and have researched,
you know,
cannabis oils and taking
CBD and myself on.
I am interested in as someone who takes
pharmaceutical medication as cannabis as
an alternative,
but my perspective and once again versus
recreational versus I would consider
that for me medical use,
um, there's a great deal of
misinformation. I mean, just
like the pharmaceutical,
I mean we have all these things that are
getting pumped into our homes all the
time with all of these side effects
and side effects and side effects.
More than half the commercial
is all side effects,
but yet it's telling you it's okay to
take that. It's cool to take that. Yeah,
it can probably kill you, but it's okay
to take that. But you can't take, yeah,
take this one and take this one,
but don't take this thing over
here that can actually help you.
Exactly.
I agree with that and I think that's
because there are people that benefit from
our equity, like us not being
literal about the subject.
I have to realize like why,
why we're here for this video is pushing
information and for recreational drug
purposes and like the misinformation.
But I think that it takes a lot more
education and usually a really bad
circumstance for you to want to change
around your life and be like, fuck,
what am I doing?
Like there has to be more than this,
but most people never get uncomfortable
enough to need to make that.
And so I'm,
I'm just not going to push it because I
just think that it's going to end up way
more negative unfortunately.
Oh,
hey guys,
it's Kendra from jubilee media.
Thank you so much for watching
this episode of middle ground.
We really try to inspire radical
empathy through our episode,
so make sure you let us know what
you thought in the comments below.
Subscribe false on Instagram
and we'll see you next time.